-Now, Nicole, we've known
each other a long time,
and I think I know
you pretty well,
but I was hoping to get
to know you a little better.
It is time for "50 Yes Or No's."
♪♪
-♪ "50 Yes Or No's" ♪
♪ "50 Yes Or No's" ♪
-Are you ready for this? Okay.
-Yeah, I'm ready.
Yeah.
-Were you born in Hawaii?
Yes.
-Did you grow up in Sydney,
Australia.
-Oh, sorry.
It feels like we're on a --
Yeah, no, I'll just -- Yes.
-Do you know how to surf?
-Bodysurf.
-Ever been to the
Sydney Opera House?
-Yes. I was there
two nights ago.
-Do you like opera?
-Yes, I was seeing an opera.
-Really?
-Dude, is this planned?
-Did you study ballet
in high school?
-High school.
-Do you like being Australian?
-I'm Australian
and I'm American.
-Is summer better than fall?
-I like fall very much.
-I knew you were gonna say that!
Honestly, I knew it.
-Did you?
-Have you taken down
your Christmas decorations yet?
-Of course.
-Can you do a cartwheel?
-I think I can, but my daughters
would say no,
but I'm working on it.
-Were you shy as a child?
-Yes.
-Do you still think
of yourself as shy?
-Working on it.
-Was one of your first films
called "BMX Bandits"?
-Yes.
-Were you in the 1995 film
"Batman Forever"?
-I was.
-Can a text message ever have
too many exclamation points?
-Yes,
and I'm probably guilty of it.
-Do you have any pet alpacas?
-Yes.
-Do you ever pet
your pet alpacas?
-Kiss them.
-Are koalas cuter
than wallabies?
-Yes.
-Were you surprised
with how "The Undoing" ended?
-No.
-Do you like country music?
-Yes.
-Do you have any tattoos?
-No.
-Have you ever gone skydiving?
-Yes.
-Have you ever done a keg stand?
-No, I've not done that.
-Have you ever played beer pong?
-What's that?
-Do you think
you could beat me in beer pong?
-I don't even know
how to play it,
so I would never
be able to beat you.
-Is "Mario Kart" a good game
to play on a first date?
Oh, come on.
-You tell me.
-Do you think there's
a chance that life
is just a computer simulation?
-No. Oh, that has no romance
to it at all.
-Are sunsets better
than sunrises?
-Yeah.
-If given the chance,
would you want to go to Mars?
-Yes.
-Can you do 20 push-ups
in a row?
-Yes.
-Was it intense to
work with legendary director
Stanley Kubrick
in "Eyes Wide Shut"?
-Yes, but extraordinary.
-Do you use emojis
when you text your friends?
-Yeah.
-Do you put sugar
in your coffee?
-Yeah.
-Is pie pretty much
always better than cake,
but we're all just
pretending otherwise?
-No.
-Are you wearing
Chanel No. 5 right now?
-No.
[ Sniffs ]
Musk and patchouli.
-Are you a neat freak?
-Occasionally.
-Are you a night owl?
-Yeah, turning into one.
-Is it ever okay
to eat pizza crust first?
-Yeah, yeah, when it's
really crispy and thin.
-Can you speak Russian?
-A little.
-Have you ever swam with sharks?
-Yes.
-Is it okay to take off
your shoes on a plane?
-And put on socks?
-No, I think they meant, like,
the people that
just take them right off.
-I'm so literal.
-Do you still have your outfits
from "Moulin Rouge!"?
-No. I wish.
-Is the greatest thing
you'll ever learn just to love
and be loved in return?
-Yeah.
-Would you want to be
25% happier,
but the catch is,
you have to walk 25% slower?
-Mm...sure. I walk quite far.
Yeah, sure, I'd give that up.
-Do you like road trips?
-Yeah! Fabulous.
-Are clowns scary?
-No.
-Have you ever been star-struck?
-Mm-hmm. Absolutely.
Right now.
-Thank you.
It took you too long.
Do you sing in the shower?
-Yep.
-Last question.
Would I look good in a fedora?
-Mnh-mnh.
-We did it, 50 questions.
[ Dinging ]
-That looks terrible!
[ Both laugh ]
-But how does
Duran Duran pull it off?
And he looked cool.
-Did they?
-Yes.
-Yeah, no, he did look cool.
Yeah.
-He's the best-looking dude
I've ever seen.
-You need a bigger hat.
-It doesn't fit.
Bigger than this?
-No, it looks too small.
No, well, I mean, just
the whole thing doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
Get it off quick! No!
You can definitely
get a better fedora than that!
-What are you talking about?
-Who chose that?
What do you -- I think
you're out of your mind.
This is, like, my thing,
I think.
-I think you are.
You're out of your mind.
-Oh, I can't believe that.
I think this looks --
-Get it off!
-I think what would happen is,
people would go,
"Are you wearing a hat?
[ Both laugh ]
People wouldn't even realize
I'm wearing one.
They'd be like,
"Can I get you drink?
What's up?
And I'd go, "Oh, I thought
I brought my hat."
And I'd go, "Oh, where is it?
Oh, I'm wearing it."
-Then you'd turn and knock
somebody out with the brim.
-But if I wear it like that...
-No. No. No.
Just the whole thing
doesn't work.
-My thanks to Nicole Kidman.
"The Undoing"
is available now on HBO Max.